bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovi dio sono fa vj ed oggi
siamo su un make up i film che un gioco
fighissimo che ho visto all'e3 di los
angeles tipo happy with no per la
felicità il paese con senza al passato
solo con la verdura quella senza padrone
questa non era felice per niente ma
manco per il cazzo che sta facendo a e
per leggere i giornali stanno non lo
puoi semplicemente aprire che il
problema sembra la macchinetta che fa
tipo l'acqua frizzante non trascura il
senso profondo che succede cos'è
oddio 9 ottobre del 64 non l'hai presa
non la prete ribelle che è ribelle non
ha preso la pillola della felicità va
bene remember bisogna fare hanno buttate
perfetto vai vai vai va bene così forte
sega forte sega liste pillole di merda
ma vabbè mica che kaz 6 magic johnson un
fenomeno non l'hai presa bravo meglio
così perché la fine le pillole o queste
qua ti ti ti ti schmidt che hanno tutto
il cervello quindi forte sega delle
pillole della felicità cioè in poche
parole ragazzi secondo me hai esagerato
col make up sia la presa lei perfetta
averi che contenta meno male fa rialzare
famiglie ora in teoria queste pillole
qua cento zia e non ho capito il ragazzo
andata sorella sorella bella si sia
inutile che parli tanto non ti capisco
diocesano intercetti chiare o il sotto
non devo superare questa linea preferite
the real non auto rai set personal
behind this point quella come sono
trasgressivo senti l'adrenalina che ti
sale nel corpo comunque l'inizio di
questo gioco
welcome back bella scritta comunque
dicevo l'inizio di questo gioco io l'ho
già visto perché era l'e3 di los angeles
l'ho sentito anch'io sta roba
salve senta lei è felice per caso no
perché le fico due schiaffi ciao ciao
non disturbiamo e ragazzi che si stanno
divertendo andiamo avanti no comunque
bruttissimo alla scena siamo indietro
col lavoro non indietro quanto lo sono
io che i compiti zio tranquillo ellissi
mosto schermo madonna quanto inquietante
tutti cadute ma che cazzo state facendo
quella è una pignata non credo funzioni
così la pignata la dovuta prendere e vi
due temi ma dovete ben darvi con la
pigna è sbagliato non sapete giocare al
suo gioco non lo fate
e va bene lo faccio come mi sento come
me
ma chi ha perso tutto il nostro ma non
me la ricordavo giuro ma che schifo
nicchia non ti limone re manco fossi
selena gomez si e no forse sera come si
però vabbè no non aprendo questa la
infili 6 dove te la infili sai dove è
inutile che te la prendi oh cazzo non
scappare
scappa scappa scappa minchia quanti
compiti che brutta stanza perché si
faccia di colico perfetto vai veloce
veloce situazione di quale veloce mica
che ansia fino a che cosa si è mangiato
un topo che schifo
sono vivo tutto agile sono tutto agile
porca [ __ ] ce l'ho fatta veloce veloce
veloce veloce apri apri apri apri apri
problema in carmelo tiro in faccia
fortissimo ok forse non è servito a
molto però ci ho provato va bene
ricapitolando una tipa si è mangiata un
topo che all'inizio era una pignatta e
ha tentato di fare la sexy come però io
non ho preso le pillole quindi si sono
incazzati e mi hanno picchiato
fantastico quindi in poche parole sto
gioco qua se non prendi le pillole sei
uno stronzo ma non ho capito scusate ma
non hanno preso voleva solo ficcarmi un
calcio e basta non ho capito perché mi
hanno lasciato oddio sono minchia seno
quello di ratatouille linguini mica
linguini il ratatouille sono tre minuti
fin quando ha picchiato e poi non
non mi prendono sono scemi va bene lo
stesso andiamo avanti
se il cibo preferito di selena gomez 0
sappilo non prendo le pillole ma mangio
i topi un bel gioco ragazzi ecco perché
mi hanno chiuso qua dentro
mi hanno chiuso qua dentro lasciandomi
morire ecco perché mi hanno lasciato qua
mi sembrava strano che mi sono lasciato
andare per creare diversi oggetti come
tipo di mandello eccolo qua basic law
cpic kraft alaska si emigrati v skyrim
mi chiama fighissimo non credo si aprono
così le porte si operò prova cini muove
bravi un fenomeno ce l'ho fatta ragazzi
sono uscito andrea salve questo è
successo il caso c'è un telecomando ha
guardato pomeriggio 5 con barbara d'urso
è definito così la papera di rubber
perché avevo in a papera di gomma
vabbè non facciamoci domande me lo porto
via perché io sono suo amico trova un
amico trova un tesoro sono compresi
anche gli insetti se mi portò via su
tizio è tutto il pacchetto completo
vabbè diciamo che lo metto a dormire
facciamo prima buonanotte zio ecco
esattamente così si dorme stage niente
raga usciamo voglio solo capire è chiusa
elettronicamente a può schierare stucco
no veramente oa chiarato il corso ma
mica sono un fenomeno mister robot può
accompagnare so mi sono pagato in mano
tutto vi cazzo di nascosto brutto
pezzente
ciao frate aspetta che io gioco con
questo io melo su chi bene bene frate è
volevi combattere quei pugni e basta
allora vinse rischio trova qualcosa tipo
una key card un cassonetto a dormire
anche te faccio prima posso lanciarlo
best gioco dell'anno ragazzi non ho
capito cosa può fare qua dentro
apro la porta stack al cavo a prima
porta credo abbia funzionato non ne sono
sicurissimo credo di sì perfetto
e stranissimo sto gioco raga non capisco
se devo semplicemente sono uscito cazzo
sono all'aperto ce l'ho fatta
si chiamerà così facile ciao zia
buongiorno ho avuto una giornata di
merda
questo è successo perché sei scalza
sull'asfalto spiegamelo tu mica sono
tutti felici sporcato di dio guarda un
pomeriggio cinque sono credo che posso
andare peggio
quanta voglia di vivere che già sta
gente porca eva giocata è più che
vicenda ancora di più a pensavo
interagissero tra di loro si sono frame
donati subito che cazzo corri tu siamo
andati alla scuola insieme
non credo
porca [ __ ] ma chi è sto tizio posso
bloccare i proiettili con un'arma è così
cercate di arma e mi chiamo scudo
smettila di lanciarmi le cose è rotto
chiaro e basta deficiente e morto a
obama quanta gente c'è e va bene si
sentì elvis presley no vabbè rega devo
scappare c'è troppa gente
porca [ __ ] perché i problemi anno non
mette rif
se sentite io non so cosa iscritto ma mi
aprista porta ti prego non scavalchi
ascom zio non mi seguono più hanno
niente a posto non vi seguono più ma non
quello è tutto scemo
questo dovrebbe essere una specie di
trappola per cosa cos'è limbo va bene
disarm vabbè tanto ci sono passato sotto
sono stato un fenomeno che è il maniaco
che non voleva che qualcuno entra
salve guardi ho trovato le trappole ma
non sono piazzate benissimo quindi sono
riusciti entrato sei soggetti esco
subito zia e scusami solo controllare
cosa c'è al piano di sopra che mi piace
tanto sta a casa
compratevi delle scarpe ragazzi che sono
utili in questo caso quando tutto pieno
di rottami in giro non mi offre in te ho
rubato delle cose ma va bene sto
continuando a rubare le cose ma
chissenefrega tanto la tipa è scema la
tipa non è scema la tipa incazzata
veloce e veloce veloce sto uscendo
grazie dell'ospitalità siete tutti i
gentilissimi grazie ormai sono uscito
qui in teoria non dovrebbe riuscire a è
andato in scena scappo in teoria tanto
non possono picchiare una donna amica
picchio le donne io dove sta
e qui che deve trovare old bridge bene
dove attraversato ponte sono non posso
devo arrivare dall'altra parte
fantastico posso essere più
rincoglionito di così si può essere più
deficienti porca di una eva la cosa ma
come new game quando la morte permanente
attiva al tuo personaggio muore
definitivamente se muore [ __ ] non
lo sapevo
non lo sapevo quindi se muoio muoio
definitivamente dori partire all'inizio
anche cazzo si è beccato mi che avevano
fatto tanti amici ho sbagliato acli
cartasso scusami ma giuro zio ho
sbagliato veramente fratello scherzavo
mi chiami ha visto era verso già
sanguinando caso non si fanno queste
cose in pubblico come che tutti girano
con le clave ma cosa vuoi ma ce l'ho con
lui non con voi varcava perché tutti
quanti si coalizzano e vabbè mi lanciai
sassi porca di una eva sono troppi a
[ __ ] deve morire la famiglia
ma quello è tutto scemo qual è il tuo
quoziente intellettivo da 1 a quello di
una pera con ragazzi per me direi che
basta così sono contentissimo di aver
giocato sta roba è figo che puoi fare
tante cose tipo raccogliere di rosa
chiotti prendere a pugni rosa chiotti
comunque ragazzo di spero che video vi
sia piaciuto
ti piace che leggo giornali in casa tua
zio sei contento a noi non frega un
cazzo
chi vedo bene zia ti vedo bene 72 un
bello e fascino insta cita belli tuoi
occhiali sei proprio fashion avrà
ragazzi allora sentite facciamo così io
concludo con l'episodio devo capire un
attimino meglio di che cosa si tratta ma
è comunque veramente figo per quanto sia
abbastanza inquietante comunque a parte
prendere sei scema queste scema ma cosa
vuoi non si picchiano le donne va bene
mi hai ruggito in faccia zia lo prendo
come un insulto
non ho capito perché va bene ragazzi
allora parte questo spero che vi sia
piaciuto cose che mi piace il momento
non mi piace anche ai vari social che i
comuni sotto tale descrizione fatemi
sapere di più sulla trama se lo sapete
perché se ne sapete qualcosa perché sono
curiosissimo di sapere di che si tratta
più di preciso i ragazzi sono già messi
disegnati ci vediamo così il video era
ragazzi